have you ever employed autocorrection in
your email writing or relied on
suggested replies on LinkedIn if yes you
owe a not to natural language processing
are also known as NLP we encounter
various applications of NLP in our daily
tasks streamlining our lives are you
interested in acquiring these skills
that underpin these tools and dwelling
into the fascinating realm of NLP where
machines comprehend human language
alongside its context one stumbling
block of students exploring NLP is a
lack of clarity on which topics to
prioritize and where to find
comprehensive learning resources in this
video we will explore the sequential
learning path for NLP covering topics
from fundamental to Advanced addressing
the skills for NLP NLP road map and
applications before moving on what NLP
is if you want to become an AI expert
and Gain handsome salary packages look
at the wide range of AIML courses by
simply learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of our certification
programs you can gain expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering chat gbd explainable AI
machine learning algorithms supervised
and unsupervised learning model training
and optimization and there is much more
on the list with the hands on experience
in tools like chat GPT d a python open
CV and tens oflow you will catch the eye
of top recruits so what are you waiting
for hurry up and enroll now one year
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses find the course Link in
the description box below so without any
further delay let's get started first
one what is NLP natural language
processing NLP constitutes a sector of
Art artificial intelligence focused on
textual and speech data this technology
enables machines to comprehend
scrutinize and handle human language
extract valuable information in the
process now let's understand who is an
NLP engineer a natural language
processing engineer or NLP engineer is a
professional responsible for crafting
and constructing computer systems that
can process assess and produce human
life language NLP branches out into
numerous captivating domains including
semantic analysis sentiment analysis
face recognition machine translation and
speech
recognition now the reach of NLP extends
across a diverse spectrum of
applications notably featuring virtual
assistance chat Bots sentiment analysis
customer service interactions and
language translation the task of NLP
Engineers involves erecting these
Innovative applications and seamlessly
embedding them into existing Frameworks
now the average salary of an NLP
engineer is 10 lakhs per anom in India
in us the annual wage of NLP Engineers
is about
$120,000 per an now let us understand
the skills required to become an NLP
engineer becoming a natural language
processing engineer entails the
acquisition of diverse set of skills and
knowledge some of these Encompass the
first one as Python Programming Mastery
of at least one programming language
such as python Java or C++ coupled with
solid grasp of data structures
algorithms and the principles of
software engineering is important next
is grasp of machine learning building a
strong foundation in machine learning
algorithms encompassing both supervised
and unsupervised learning is important
familiarity with Advanced Techniques
like convolutional neural networks or
also known as CNN and recurrent neural
networks also known as RNN is vital the
third one being NLP techniques
cultivating a deep understanding of NLP
techniques which encompasses facets like
text preprocessing syntactic and
semantic analysis and the intricate
domain of sentiment
analysis fourth one is NLP Library Li
iies and Frameworks navigate easily
through the NLP libraries and Frameworks
such as the natural language toolkit or
nltk Spacey Stanford core NLP and jesm
harnessing their capabilities to
streamline your NLP and div the fifth
one is data science Acumen developing a
sound grasp of data science principles
and compassing facets such as data
visualization statistical analysis and
the Art of data manipulation is
important armed with this multifaceted
skill set you will be primed to embark
on a journey as an accomplished NLP
engineer who is ready to navigate the
complexities of natural language and
contribute to the exciting world of NLP
Innovations now the important point of
today's session that is the road map to
become an NLP engineer here is a
comprehensive professional strategy or
trajectory for those aspiring to become
adept natural language processing
Engineers the first one is Educational
Foundation embark on your journey by
pursuing a degree in a pertinent field
such as Compu science Linguistics or
artificial intelligence many
accomplished NLP Engineers hold Advanced
degrees either a master's or a PhD in
these domains next one is internship for
entry-level Ventures consider immersing
yourself in Practical experience through
internships or entry-level positions
within the industry these opportunities
not only equip you with Hands-On
expertise but also Aid in constructing a
robust portfolio moreover they
facilitate the establishment of valuable
professional connections next is skills
and knowledge acquisition develop a
comprehensive grasp of the essential
proficiencies requisites for an NLP
engineer this encompasses programming
press machine learning Acumen NLP
techniques familiarity with pertinent
libraries and Frameworks Proficiency in
data science and the owning of
communication and teamwork
competencies next is portfolio
development create a diverse portfolio
teaming with projects that eliminate
your capabilities and expertise projects
like a sophisticated chatbot a sentiment
analysis tool or a language model can
substantiate your aptitude for solving
real world NLP challenges and validate
your skill set for potential employers
now the next one networking Endeavors
engage in conferences meetups and
Industry events to forge connections
with fellow NLP professionals this
affords opportunities to remain AB
breast of the latest developments in the
field and exposes you to an area of NLP
applications next is specialization
consideration Ponder the prospect of
specializing in a specific NLP realm be
it machine translation speech Rec nition
or conversational agents this
specialization not only differentiates
you in the job market but also enables
you to attain expertise within a
particular niche in submission the path
towards becoming an NLP engineer entails
a fusion of educational attainment
handson experience and the Mastery of an
Eclectic area of skills and knowledge
domains now we will discuss the
applications of NLP natural language
processing boths an extensive area of
applications extending well beyond the
following 10 examples we have chatbots
intelligent replies on chatbot platform
which as email or LinkedIn virtual
assistance in Customer Care Services
spelling check and grammar correction
and with that we have come to an end of
this session on NLB road map I hope you
found it valuable and entertaining
please ask any questions about the
topics covered in the session in the
comment section below our experts will
assist you in addressing your problems
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep Lear staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in colle collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here oh